oder wir bringen täglich e10 ist
wiederum wenig ich habe geschlafen bin
außen einfach geschlafen
guck mal hier jetzt die stripper noch
dreimal halbes haus weg hallo das ist
modernes kunst ok
er wirkt cool da warte ich bei meiner
familie sein offensichtlich bewusst
gerade und wählt aus einem raus dann
kriegst du dem schwert aber in die
fremde mit einem mit einem stein schwer
tja okay hier friedenszeichen und
bereitet naja ich gerne mein haus geht
mal
ich werde noch ein bisschen an mein name
meine rohstoffen arbeiten bevor ich
anfange zu bauen und wie hast du jetzt
alles umgestellt dass man die items also
diese option welche option dass man mit
der items hier dass du dir oben rechts
ist oder wie ja dass du also ich hab
jetzt wieder weg gemacht dass zwei
nerven
also ich mach jetzt ist auch weg ach so
ja du kannst aber auch drücken und dann
hast du unten links options und das noch
mal mehr einstellungsmöglichkeiten ist
es auch sehr schön muss man jetzt
eigentlich nicht unbedingt gebraucht von
machen ich will mich erst mal diese
ganzen höhenrain bevor ich die alle zu
bewegen beim haus was darüber kommt
jetzt erst mal der höhle glaube ich wenn
ihr schon einigermaßen und gewappnet
okay es geht okay ich bin schlecht
gewappnet es reicht ihr braucht jetzt
nicht vertreten witzig nie wirklich in
der teilweise witzig wenn ich selber bin
mein will aufnehme wie ich da mit mir
selber rede des viechtacher sind schon
da muss nicht sein kopf fassen denken
geborgen gott lukas verbreitest wieder
für eine scheiße was nimmst du
wiederverkauf kann ich gut dafür sehe
ich die letzten szenen folgen oder so
toll wie immer nur zusammen aufgenommen
mit mehreren leuten
und jetzt die 19.000 kamen erfolge habe
ich komplett alleine aufgenommen gestern
und was ich dann redet habe ohne wird
ich habe so einen quatsch gelagert und
aber ich glaube dass also mir selbst
gefällt hat ist nicht so viel fisch ist
die hauptsache
die gefällt man muss für sich selbst man
muss sich sehr über sich selbst lachen
findet stimmte da musste wiederum recht
geben das ist wirklich so man darf sich
einfach selbst ernst nehmen ja ich habe
einen eisernen jason spezza kripo so
jetzt packe ich erstmal meine ganzen
sachen rein wie zum beispiel marmor ist
der rennt hier darum wer will action
erleben also ich hab ich mein haus
angefangen denn ich möchte erstmal hier
höhlenforscher durch die höhen ziehen ja
habe ich mir auch gedacht dass ich
erstmalig die höhlen laufe aber durchaus
auch als inhouse oder nee ich werde
jetzt auch erstmalig die hüllen offen
ich mache mir ich hab mir jetzt gerade
ist meine kiste gestellt jetzt ein paar
items machen und dann oder wir nehmen an
dass performa also ein haus erst mal so
ein kleines plus befinden und dann damit
wenigstens bei rüdiger penunce wobei ich
find rüdiger eigentlich sehr erotisch
und deswegen lang gelben haus ja ich
finde eigentlich überhaupt serotyp 8
also spontan wieder eigentlich ganz
ausziehen müssen hat so was muss muss
erst mit ihm in der höhle ich habe jetzt
lasse ich habe crafting table allerdings
essen alles eigentlich so ich ganz eine
hülle
aber erstmal es immer was so jetzt dann
stoßen wir wahrscheinlich auf eine
chance kriegt und ich hab keinen schaden
bekommen und die vielleicht ist fast an
die ich da schon die höhle wird fast
schon wieder vorbei ist sie aber nicht
das ist glaube ich ja das eisen habe ich
schon mal dass die zutaten für ein für
bessere sachen und für eventuelle frist
und was besser ist erstmal werkzeug
machen wir erstmal eine rüstung machen
die werkzeuge des post und dem tv oder
eine richtige richtung erfahrung dass ja
geil jetzt richtig viel kohle
das wusstest du nicht aber mir vor mir
sagen gefährlich und bewusst ist aber
ich hab so wieder verdrängt sage ich mal
also ich habe dann gesagt ach stimmt
dafür bekommt man ja auch erfahrungen
denn heilige ich kenne fackel dabei und
ich bin gott oh mein gott bin ich hier
gelandet
auch calls und überall glitzert und was
sie sonst irgendwie mal angucken und
optisch muss hier weg
ja das sind das sind ärzte die da so
cook ich dachte erst dass wir ein spiel
oder so ja aber ich bin hier als
abgebaut wenn dadurch gefallen und er
wusste überhaupt nicht mehr wo ich jetzt
eigentlich hier genau bin du das weiß
ich nie wenn ich in der höhle bin ich
brauche jetzt einfach wieder hoch weil
ich gerade angst um meine ganze drama
aus leute wenn ihr euch das mal anguckt
hier leuchten einfach so ärzte da ist
das explodierte direkt neben mir viel
leben fünf herzen ich habe so eine tolle
richtung das zum thema rüstung brauchen
wir eigentlich nicht nein aber ich habe
ja sogar zur geile ärzte gesehen habt
ein skript kurzen screenshot gemacht und
dann auf einmal steht krieger neben mir
du machst einen screenshot von ärzten ja
das war fast jeder seinen fittichen also
immer was einen an mach ich hab im rc
fetisch es ist okay ist okay also gar
nicht sitzen stehen noch füße man
striesows pampers nackt durch die gegend
rennen also ganz beispiel kabel lässt
jedoch pampers träger erklärt alte
senioren den pampers schöne grüße und
viele küsse an alle von dir von mir
viele schläge vorbild von mir alles gute
geburtstag leute nämlich geburtstag
schreibt mal auf seine seite alles gute
nein meine einer spitzhacke 1000 m fällt
mir gerade auf ich will nicht sagen aber
ich sage
obligatorisch sein ich sollte vielleicht
das essen geschafft den sex-videos
entgegen
ich glaube ich werde jetzt eine
blockhütte schnell bauen
ich glaube ich bin doch keine noch geht
noch langsam wirklich leider ein
bisschen zu oft findet gestern nacht
heftig erzählt aber er hat mich gestern
fast verschlafen hier ist auftraten
creeper im moment also das weil es
einerseits verstehe ich und einerseits
auf die krise gezogen
da braucht jetzt nicht denken dass ich
hier den krieg vor dem fcr bitte nicht
explodieren hier sind so viele schöne
ärzte kannst in der höhle echt alles ab
wanne gestern einfach mal die kommentare
schreiben was so wertvolle sachen sind
wie man später braucht weil er ich
glaube wir werden es nie hinkriegen ist
richtig geiles mit so pipelines und
alles zu bauen
ich werde mich vor informieren da werde
ich richtig was auf die beine stellen
macht das mandat also ich finde es geil
wenn du dich wirklich informieren
würdest weil schon einige vista zu
angeguckt und soll ich wie viele meinen
ärzten sind glaube ich auch für so
waffen oder bis zum werkzeug aus dem
neuen mods wir haben es so viele muss
also 750 650 x
das ist schon eine menge ich habe ihn
bisher nur was support logan angekuppelt
die werde ich mir auf jeden fall machen
und dann machten sofort nach portal
einmaleins beim spawn dass wir nicht
beim sponsoring schritt gehen muss und
dann rutscht durch ein portal immer im
haus rein und so solche gallen sachen
aber muss das verteilen der bremer aktiv
sein oder
na ja stimmt ja dann
doppel wird ich glaube es gibt aber auch
solche bücher das habe ich gesehen wenn
man man kann sich bücher schreiben wird
und man man man muss die machen und man
muss die genau dort machen das jetzt
kann ich mich nicht abbauen man muss sie
genau dort machen und dann ist es dann
teleport teleporter und muss man quasi
das buch eine recht machen und dann ist
man direkt an dem ort wo man das buch
damals geschrieben hat okay das ist geil
dazu habe ich auch ein video gesehen
habe ich aber vergessen wie das kraft
muss man noch mal angucken
aber es gibt wirklich so viele sachen
werden so was von vielen möglichkeiten
es wird einfach noch richtig richtig
geil will ich jetzt mal so sagen kann
was total kaputt weiß ich auch gerne
machen würde mir noch ein baumhaus bauen
sich diese von auf baumhäuser wie er
jedem tisch ich habe als kind habe ich
mal euch immer in unseren garten
baumhaus aber wir haben leider keinen
baum der groß genug waren es
ausgerechnet
dennoch hatte damals im baumhaus
obstbäume und damit ich da einmal
runtergefallen und dann das war genau an
dem geburtstag von kumpel von mir und
ich war da oben und dazu kommen wir
wollten gerade im schwimmbad fahren
glaube ich ich war darunter und am
knöchel angestaut die fahren zum arzt
und ich habe natürlich erst mal gehofft
dass der mann ja alles nicht passiert
oder so und ja packt erstmal verband
darum jetzt erstmal zwei drei tage dusch
mit müllsack und alles drumherum
jeder der schon mal einen bruch hatte
oder irgend sowas der weiß ist duschen
mit müll sagt jetzt bescheid damit zum
tüten packen mit der gibt's nicht nass
wird
es ist sowas von behindert
du kannst du musst einfach für alles
seine linke hand benutzen seit für
zähneputzen seither wieder krieg für
alles als spielereien spielereien die
der kongress eigentlich jeden tag dank
früherer und schon wieder so ein
bevor sich zum kleinsten ist etwas was
in der ersten folge auch in dem
geschrieben stand dann ändern wenn ja
das scheint einer das ja und dann sagt
sie so ehrlich twitter gerade heute
gelebte tötete der standard seien alle
bin jetzt ein paar gänge durch häufig
schon so viele ärzte mit kopie des
inventars voll
so war die wehr jetzt erst mal hoch
gehen oder mich sagen erst mal ohne
können entspannt haus ich versuche jetzt
in diesem haus schon diese nach zu
pendeln das schaffst du nicht mehr
schaffe ich nicht leiste wird dunkel
wäre der beste bitte komm doch jetzt
stehen wir die ganze dienst winziges
haus ein
das winzigste haushaltspanels scharf und
gar keine wolle nachricht des weges gott
schnellste rüdiger ich komme barzel part
of his bisschen ruhiger ich glaube wir
gerade die höhe raus so ich hab jetzt
den weg macht ich noch ruhige debatte
weiter sind reicher
ich werde das machen hätte hast du auch
schon wettbewerber liegen für einen
klasse bei weniger pendler ist danach
einfach mit das mache ich gar nicht so
was ja ich muss trotzdem zum überlaufen
ja geht um mal zurück aber ich dass ich
doch einfach pervers anfassen ja ich hab
gleich ein trauma erlitt nur das gefällt
mir vielleicht nicht okay da war schon
wieder eine talentprobe ab wenn am ende
dieses folge sieht es da schon draußen
was ich dazu hochladen wollte es kommt
nämlich heute ich glaube es ist gut
rausgekommen aufnehmen soll ich liegt
bei rüdiger drin erwartet sich ganz kurz
zu
naja ich ein kurzes stück so ganz ob zu
neben der aufnahme
mach das mal